e aí
e qual foi a última vez que você
caminhou para trás e
e qual foi a última vez que você ficou
de cócoras essa
e qual foi a última vez que você sentou
no chão ou melhor quando é que você
fugiu desse padrão de movimento
contemporâneo que é sentar levantar e
deitar
a cada vez mais um ambiente que a gente
está inserido faz com que a gente se
afaste da nossa naturalidade do
movimento e como isso como resultado
disso a gente acaba ficando limitado
engessado rígido de alguma forma a nossa
espécie ela desenvolveu o mesmo
movimento e o estilo de vida fisicamente
ativo em nem para nós seres humanos e
e em 1903 o educador físico francês
tenente da marinha ele corre de novo
evacuação de 700 pessoas durante a
erupção vulcânica cerca de 30 mil
pessoas morreram durante a erupção foi
há mais devastadora que se tem
conhecimento e ele tem uma crença que
todo mundo deve desenvolver uma força
física e que devemos de que somos na
verdade seres altruístas devemos ser
generosos busca ajudar o próximo sem
interesse e este evento dessa erupção
surgiu profundos efeitos nele e ele
pensou que provavelmente aquelas pessoas
tivesse o estilo de vida fisicamente
ativos ela se relacionasse mais com o
movimento as conseguiriam ter salvada
salvada ajudado o próximo então ele vai
dizer que devemos ser forte mas para ser
útil ser forte para cinto
e isso tudo bem que provavelmente a
gente não vai precisar fugir de um
vulcão mas será que a gente tá realmente
sendo forte para seu será que a gente tá
enxergando o movimento um estilo de vida
fisicamente ativo é a maneira que ele
pode e deve ser enxergado afinal de
contas todos os rápidos impactos
positivos da atividade física do
exercício físico na nossa saúde na nossa
qualidade de vida mas é muito mais que
isso concordando com essa crença de
george que devemos ser forte para ser
útil e que somos seres altruístas é
necessário e importante nos
movimentarmos para nos conectarmos
socialmente para jogar laços criar
conexões afinal de contas somos seres
biopsicossociais
é uma grande pesquisa realizada em água
e durante muito tempo envolvendo
diferentes tipos de pessoas diferentes
comportamentos diferentes condições
socioeconômicas traz uma perspectiva
diferente sobre a felicidade primeiro a
gente cresce acreditando e ouvindo que a
gente só vai ser feliz se tiver um carro
maneiro a grana na conta uma casa para
cana mas tem gente que tem tudo isso e
tá infeliz e
bom então a pesquisa real a pesquisa diz
o seguinte que a felicidade ela pré
sério sucesso e que os nossos movimentos
as nossas interações sociais elas são um
caminho para uma vida mais feliz e
e a pesquisa também vai trazer alguns
capitaliza dores da felicidade algumas
ações algumas atitudes que a gente pode
adotar para ter um pensamento mais
positivo e assim mudar um pouco a
perspectiva aquilo que nos rodeia e um
dos desses capitaliza dores é o tema da
cidade x é o movimento movimentos
caminho along jovem dance cure corra
subir escada pule corda não importa como
contanto que vocês estejam em movimento
e que por meio do movimento vocês possam
criar conexões gerar veículos né criar
laços bons relacionamentos eles vão
trazer maior sensação de bem-estar menos
estresse e assim a gente vai poder ter
uma maior utilidade aproveitamento da
vida
e portanto eu desejo que vocês se
movimentem não somente para evitar
doenças ou para ter um corpo bonito mas
se você tinha movimente para se conectar
com aquilo que realmente importa para
vocês tem que quando chegar ao final da
vida a gente possa olhar para trás e
tenho orgulho dos movimentos realizados
sejam fortes para ser outro muito
obrigado tá
e aí